Oh,
I think so.
Yeah.
I don't think it's any time soon.
I think we have to first be treated
equally within society.
Uh,
and once we are treated equally within
society,
we then have an opportunity for
[inaudible] to participate more fully.
You think of it this way,
there's over 500,000 elected official
positions in the United States of
America,
500,000 from local city council to water
district and president of the United
States.
There's less than 300 who are openly gay
or lesbian,
bisexual,
or transgender.
So that's a long way to go in terms of
represent elected representation of a
community that is certainly much larger
than its elected representation is
within that community.
Um,
so we have a ways to go in that respect,
but I,
I,
I think that day will come.